so let's talk about the best way to
prepare your eggs for
maximum nutrition and i'm mainly talking
about
the carotenoids in the eggs lutein
and zeaxanthin both of these
are very powerful compounds
in certain foods that have very unique
health benefits
they're in vegetables egg yolks shrimp
lobster salmon and there's quite a few
others it's in
avocados but these two specific
compounds
accumulate mostly in the eye they also
go into the liver
and certain parts of your brain but most
of it goes into the
eye part of the retina which is the
extension of the brain it's all
neurological tissue
and the back part the center part it's
called the macula
and also in the lens of the eye so both
of these compounds
can help reduce the risk of age-related
macular degeneration as well as
cataracts now i would also recommend
avoiding things that cause inflammation
specifically vegetable oils
soy corn oil canola
and cottonseed oil those are very
inflammatory
and they create a lot of free radical
damage creating destruction to your
tissue so the combination of avoiding
the omega-6 fatty acids
and consuming foods high in these two
compounds
can help decrease the risk of damage to
your macula
as well as your lens now with a cataract
things are going to be cloudy
okay like an opaque type cloudiness
on the eye but if there's degeneration
in the macula you're going to lose
vision in the central part as well as
things are going to be less defined
these two compounds also prevent the
blue light they
filter out blue light they actually
absorb the blue light
and so that's another benefit also
they're anti-inflammatory
they're very powerful antioxidants so
now that you understand
the power of these two chemicals and
eggs
how do you maximize nutrition how do you
prepare your eggs
well they're very sensitive to heat so
the less
you heat them the more nutrition you're
going to have so
like if you're going to fry an egg over
easy so the yolk is runny
if you're going to boil egg don't
overcook it
poached eggs are really good if you're
going to scramble the egg
just try not to overcook it too much now
should you consume raw eggs now the
problem with that is when you consume
raw egg whites it can deplete other
nutrients
like biotin so i recommend cooking the
white part
but leave the yolk runny and of course
if you're new to my channel you want to
consume
pasture-raised organic eggs
thanks for watching before you go if you
have a question about a product
or you're new to keto and you want to
know how to begin
keto or you're on keto and you need a
debug because it's not going as smooth
i have a keto consultant standing by to
help you
this is just for the people in the us
hopefully in the future we'll be able to
answer everyone's call
but i put the number down below so you
can call
and get some help